Slightly more challenging to program is the function median.
Now the median of this list is the middle element of the sorted list,
which in this case will be 2.
Of course, if there is an even number of elements--
let me just add one--
the median isn't exactly defined.
So let's say I pick either one of the two center ones.
All the examples I'm testing with will have an odd number of elements.
Okay? So let's not worry about the case where it is of even length.
Let's just make sure our code runs for an odd length.
So this one is more complicated to program, and there are two hints.
First, there is a function called "sorted."
You can give a data, and the output of the function gives you a sorted list.
That's built into Python, so we don't have to worry about how to sort things.
Luckily not.
It will be used to assign this to a new list,
and the way you do this, you just give it a name.
Say sorted data is data.
That gives you a sorted list.
The second thing to know is
if you want to access any element in a structure like this
or in a structure like this, you can do this using notation like this.
Now this is the tricky thing. This doesn't give you the third element in the list.
It gives you the fourth, and the reason is each list is indexed starting with zero.
So this list has five elements, and the indices go from zero to four.
So to go to the center element,
you would have to use index number two,
and that gives you effectively the third element in the list.
I apologize for this. This is all over computer science,
that the indices tend to run from zero on,
not from number one on, whereas in the English language
we use one as the first index.
Some programming languages use one, some use zero.
Python uses zero, so you have to know this.
With those hints, you should be able to fill in the gaps,
write your code over here, return something,
and if you print the median off this data sequence over here,
then it should output a 2, which is the median.
So here is the code.
To solve this, first make a new sorted list of the data
and then find the corresponding element in the list to return.
Let's assume there is an odd number of items in the list
so things should always be fine.